[Music]
[Applause]
since it achieved independence the
United States of America has been a
beacon of democracy for people and
nations around the world I like many
Americans take pride in our free and
open system of government and as a
Department of Homeland Security
appointee under president george w bush
i worked hard to keep our nation safe if
therefore pains me to say that at least
as of the date this lecture is being
taped in late summer 2018 our election
system the very essence of our democracy
is insecure and quite vulnerable to
manipulation indeed it's clear now that
it was manipulated by russia in 2016
although the circumstances an impact of
that manipulation are still under
investigation as I speak even more
worrisome is that there's good reason to
believe that Russia's interference has
not ceased new efforts appear to be
underway to manipulate the system again
in the 2018 midterm elections should you
care I think you should in fact I dare
say that this problem is one of the most
important facing America today to be
sure it isn't existential in the same
way that Seiya
a nuclear war would be but at the same
time a trustworthy system of elections
is what makes our country function and
it's what gives our leaders legitimacy
nothing quite literally nothing is more
singularly significant in American
government than the ritual of voting and
the quadrennial peaceful transition of
power it would be a tragedy of the
gravest type where Americans to lose
confidence in the integrity of our
elections it would shake the foundations
of our political system with unknowable
results so
in this lecture I'd like to help you
understand what makes our election
system so insecure explain what we know
about Russia interference with that
system and how we know it and propose
some solutions that are within our
ability to implement if we can muster
the national will tact let's begin by
considering our election infrastructure
the term really covers more than just
things such as voting machines and
databases because it's fundamentally a
distributed system by which Americans
vote in elections the idea of a single
unified system is a bit of an illusion
the United States really has not one
election system but more than 50 because
every state and US territory operates
its own election infrastructure despite
the diversity each system has six
integrated parts the first part of any
election system is registration this is
when you sign up to vote and in essence
get an authorization to do so often in
the form of a voting card the
registration system is very different
from the actual voting system itself as
you probably know if you're an American
of voting age you don't have to register
directly with election officials you can
do it when you get a driver's license in
a new state or other jurisdiction that's
how I got my registration in the
District of Columbia or if you're
naturalized as an American citizen you
might have registered at the time you
took the oath of citizenship so the
registration system itself is very
diverse and while that's convenient
it also means the system offers more
points of vulnerability to attack the
second system within this system of
elections is the database of registered
voters typically that's maintained by
each state all of the states various
points of registration feed into a
single unified database of voters that
database stores information on who you
where you live and what party you're
with it tracks whether you voted in the
last election or not and if you move
across state lines you get deleted from
one state database and entered into
another this database is probably the
most vulnerable place within each
state's election system because it is
the point where any or all of the
state's voter rolls could be eliminated
by malicious interference just by way of
example during the 2018 primaries Los
Angeles County accidentally lost more
than a hundred and eighteen thousand
voters from its voter rolls now imagine
if that were done deliberately by some
malicious actor the third piece of the
puzzle is what are known as voting logs
these are the voting books that are
created for each voting precinct the
smallest subdivision of a state for
voting purposes in other words the large
database that's maintained by the state
of California or the state of Illinois
is abstracted into a precinct level
voting book that is created for the
location where you vote the book tells
election officials for example that
Professor rosensweig is a Republican
give him a Republican ballot or he's a
Democrat give him a Democratic ballot in
the primary it says that I'm qualified
to vote for the presidential election
and on a referendum but perhaps not to
vote on this particular property tax
issue because I don't own any property
the process of subdividing the database
into voting books is another point of
vulnerability and it's often done with
the help of private companies who may or
may not be more secure than the state is
so only now do we finally get to the
vote itself the fourth part of the
overall election system you go to your
precinct polling station you show your
ID if it's required the poll worker
checks you off in the voting book that
was pulled from the state database
which in turn was derived from your
original registration perhaps 12 or 15
years ago and finally they give you a
ballot and send you off to the voting
booth to vote now as a general matter
there are at least three different types
of voting systems in use in America
today there are a few states nearly 20
as of this taping where people still
vote by paper ballot only people check a
box or fill in an oval and then their
ballots are optically scanned and
counted three of the states use mail-in
voting for almost all elections so we
can include them among the paper ballot
states most other states now use some
form of electronic voting or a
combination of paper ballots and
electronic voting that is you go into
the voting booth and instead of having a
piece of paper that will later be put
into an optical scanner you have an
electronic system where you tap on the
screen to vote for your candidate I tap
here
I vote for Donald Trump I tap here I
vote for Hillary Clinton
now critically there are two different
types of electronic voting one is called
direct electronic voting or electronic
voting only where the only record of
what you do is electronic and the other
is electronic with paper backup where
you complete and submit your electronic
ballot and that's what's counted but the
machine also prints out a paper backup
ballot that goes into the ballot box so
it can be reviewed if there's ever any
doubt about the validity of the
electronic voting electronic voting is a
significant area of vulnerability in our
voting system at a recent hacker
convention known as DEFCON that takes
place annually in Las Vegas they had a
little hacking village and the hackers
there took between 30 minutes and 2
hours to break the security on most of
the standard-issue electronic voting
machines and cause them to record votes
in ways that were different from the way
that the ballots
were actually being cast now that's not
an encouraging result is it so the fifth
part of the election system involves
actually taking all those votes that
were cast in each state's precincts and
adding them up so we know that say
Donald Trump won a victory in Wisconsin
and Hillary Clinton won a victory in New
York the sum of all the votes in the
precincts gets reported typically
electronically via the Internet whoops
there's more vulnerability to the
Secretary of State or whatever official
or entity serves as the top election
authority for the state that authority
then tallies all of the numbers and
reports the final totals of the votes in
the state in the case of election for
members of the US Congress or for state
government the totals determine the
winning candidates for presidential
elections as I'm sure you know the
totals are translated into electoral
votes that will later be cast by
electors for the candidates so the sixth
and final piece of this election
infrastructure this vast system of
information flows that governs how we
elect our leaders is the post election
audit what happens if there's a dispute
you've undoubtedly heard about election
recounts and they come in lots of
different flavors in a simple recount
they may just check the math to make
sure that they've tallied the numbers
correctly and that all the precinct
totals add up to the actual number of
votes for the candidate in a particular
state at the more extreme end you may
recall that in the tight 2000
presidential race between George W Bush
and Al Gore Florida election officials
in a number of counties actually pulled
out the paper ballots and looked at each
and every one and recounted every ballot
by hand and then somewhere in the middle
is what we call risk base auditing where
we take a sample of the paper ballots
that have been printed out and do a hand
count of
and then see if that hand count matches
closely enough to the reported
electronic count we wouldn't expect it
to match exactly unless we counted every
boat but if the electronic vote says 55%
for Clinton 45% for Trump and the paper
ballots say the opposite we know
something's wrong
if the paper ballot audit says 54% for
Clinton 46% for Trump everything appears
to be fine so that's the election
infrastructure but overlaying all of
that is another information system
that's the system that the parties in
the candidates use to convey their
messages to potential voters in order to
persuade us to vote and how this
includes things like candidates web
sites where they tell us what their
positions are it's their advertising in
which they tell us what they'll do if
elected social media campaigns where the
candidates put out tweets and maintain
Facebook pages that advocate their
positions it includes efforts to get
their supporters to create their own
social media campaigns about what the
candidates views are and what voters
should support there are internal
campaign communications where candidates
and their staff plot strategy about how
to convince people to vote for them the
system also includes get-out-the-vote
programs
that's where candidates plan how to
spend money to go door to door to make
sure that people who are on their side
actually go out and vote for the
candidate on the day of election it even
includes those who influence votes like
the think tanks in Washington that
Russia has tried to compromise even
though this entire cloud of information
is separate from the actual voting
itself it plainly has a critical impact
on the voting so let's sum up what all
this election and election related
infrastructure looks like there are I
think two characteristics that deserve
to be highlighted first off
it's really quite complex as I said
there are more than 50 election systems
and thousands of county level systems
each county is naturally going to have
different resources available to it and
different training available for its
election workers that means that anyone
security response that we devise will
almost necessarily be of only limited
value because we've got disparate
systems within the United States that
are really in commensurate with one
another second our system is largely
part-time at the precinct level poll
workers volunteer or maybe they get a
little bit of pay but they've probably
got no more than two or three days of
training
they're often retirees and they are
mostly being trained about making sure
that voters are who they say they are
not anything with respect to the
security of the election system itself
and by and large these are the same
people who collect the tallies from the
voting machines and then use the
networks to sum up those tallies and
send them to the state in the county
level where they're provided to state
officials you can imagine that part-time
help can be a challenge when it comes to
good security interestingly most of the
Russian interference in the 2016
elections that has come to light was not
directed at what people generally think
of as our election infrastructure rather
the Russians operated primarily in that
second cloud of information that we've
identified the cloud of election related
persuasion and internal communications
in mid-july 2018 special counsel robert
muller who as of this taping is still
investigating russian election
interference and possible ties to
president Trump's election campaign
indicted twelve members of the GRU the
main Intelligence Service of the Russian
military the Russians were accused of
stealing information from the Democratic
National Committee from Hillary
Clinton's campaign and from the
Democratic Congressional Campaign
let's take a look at what they were up
to the Russians hacked into the systems
of the Democratic National Committee or
DNC using what was essentially an
old-school phishing attack phishing if
you don't know is when you get a phony
email with a bad link in it and if you
click on the link you get directed to a
webpage that looks like the right
webpage but it isn't and as a result you
wind up for example giving your username
and password to a hacker that's exactly
what happened to the DNC a couple of
employees there got emails that look
like they were from Google the messages
said hi someone's just used your
password to try and sign into your
Google account Google stopped this sign
in attempt you should change your
password immediately and people did but
in changing their passwords they were
telling the Russians what their old
passwords were and then what their new
passwords were going to be and that gave
the Russians access to their email from
there the Russians gained access to data
on the DNC servers a similar attack was
made on Hillary Clinton's campaign
through of all people her campaign
chairman John Podesta he got a similar
email that looked to be from Google but
instead of clicking on the link he did
the right thing and he sent the message
to his IT support team led by man named
Charles Delavan Podesta asked Delavan
what should I do with this and delavane
wrote back that the email was legitimate
and that Podesta needed to change his
password immediately and so Podesta did
that
of course Delavan was wrong here it was
a fake email and Podesta wound up giving
the Russians access to his email account
and then to Miss Clinton's servers and
then to the campaign communications that
were inside their team by the way when
mr. Delavan was confronted with his
email to Podesta he said that instead of
writing that the message Podesta
received was legitimate he had meant
typed that it was not legitimate as
perhaps not the most convincing excuse
for a pretty big mistake so how do we
know it was the Russians who hacked the
DNC and Hillary's campaign first the GRU
used the same IP addresses
that's Internet Protocol addresses each
of which is a series of numbers that
tells the internet system which specific
server or other network devices being
used they used the same IP addresses to
attack the DNC that they used a year
earlier to attack the German Bundestag
the servers were the command and control
for the operation and the Russians were
lazy and reused them sourcing this
attack physically in Russia second they
had taken some of the data that they
stole from the DNC and modified it that
is falsified it before release now you
probably know that when you modify a
document you create metadata that's
notations in the document like date
modified or modified by the Russians
accidentally left some notations behind
and they were in Russian and included
Russian language settings third the
Russians released all this information
through false personas one called DC
leaks and the other one called gusoff
err 2.0 DC leaks pretended to be an
American and gusoff ur 2.0 pretended to
be a Romanian but both of these accounts
have been linked forensic ly directly
back to the same command and control
servers in Russia that were owned
operated and maintained by the GRU in
Robert Moeller's indictment you can even
see that immediately before a particular
gusoff ur 2.0 posting the GRU officers
back in Russia were googling the exact
same phrases that became part of gusoff
ur 2.0 s message in other words they
would search for a particular English
phrase via Google perhaps because their
English wasn't so good and then that
same phrase would appear in Gusev ur 2.0
tweets the Russians also really
information through WikiLeaks the pseudo
journalistic institution run by
Australian born hacker Julian Assange
all of this evidence and more led the
intelligence community to issue a report
in January 2017 saying that it was the
Russians who were behind the attacks the
Senate Select Committee on Intelligence
in July 2018 issued a bipartisan report
supporting the intelligence community's
review saying it was a sound
intelligence product and adding their
own conclusion that the interference
campaign was personally approved by
President Vladimir Putin special counsel
Moore's indictment was so detailed that
it named the individual Russian
intelligence officials who were behind
the attack
moreover following the indictment the
New York Times reported that the
intelligence community actually had a
human source close to Vladimir Putin who
reported that Putin personally ordered
the hacking of the DNC
with the intent of aiding Donald Trump's
presidential campaign but that was just
the first part of the Russian campaign
the second part was in effect a troll
factory run by a group known as the
internet research agency that had its
headquarters in Saint Petersburg Russia
this was an attempt to create
disinformation campaigns in the social
media space of America in order to
distract disrupt and disable legitimate
communications by American citizens
about the elections one way the campaign
operated was through BOTS as you may
know bots are artificial networks of
fictitious people who post things and
then echo the posts of other BOTS so
they create the false impression that
10,000 people are retweeting or
reposting on social media about a
particular idea or concept in fact none
of them are real people convincing as
BOTS messages can be to the general
public
an analysis of BOTS behavior looks very
different
that of naturally occurring social
networks that involve say your
communication in mind when you follow me
on Twitter or when you follow the great
courses on Twitter those type of network
communications have a certain organic
naturally occurring shape that is
completely different from that of
communications on artificial bot
networks
simply put artificial networks have a
more hierarchical top-down appearance
and Russian bot networks operated
systematically to sow discord let me
give you just one example during the
election Facebook had a web page for a
man named Melvin Reddick
Melvin lived in Harrisburg Pennsylvania
he said he was originally from
Philadelphia PA he studied at the
Indiana University of Pennsylvania
he went to Central High in Philadelphia
and he posted a lot of very
controversial anti-american opinions for
example in one case he accused the
us-led coalition operating in Syria of
conducting chemical weapons attacks
there when we know in fact it was
Syria's Assad regime that was conducting
those attacks so here's the thing Melvin
Reddick didn't exist
his entire Facebook page was a fake the
profile picture of him and of his
daughter was stolen from the profile of
a Brazilian man who lives down in the
Amazon outside the main cities who had
never heard of the American elections
didn't come from Pennsylvania and
doesn't really speak much English at all
he was tracked down by a newspaper when
his picture appeared he disclaimed the
web page and said he had nothing to do
with it
the Russians simply stole his Facebook
profile photo and used it to create a
fake Facebook page sites like redick's
and the rest of the Russian bot Network
propagated false news on a mass scale in
order to stir the political pot one
example this was a report on Breitbart
news in January 2017 that a thousand man
was
mob had attacked police and set
Germany's oldest church on fire the
report complete with pictures and
details was retweeted thousands of times
and propagated throughout the American
news environment yet it was utterly
false no church had been burnt no mob
had existed the picture was actually
from a meeting of Muslim men that it
occurred several days earlier at which
no violence had occurred but he created
anger and confusion which the Russians
evidently believed would help Donald
Trump's cause even though the Russian
interference that I've described wasn't
targeted directly at our voting
infrastructure I'm afraid we can't take
much comfort in that fact the Russians
also probe the vulnerability of our
voting systems to attack we know for
example that they stole at least 75,000
election records from Illinois mr.
molars indictment says it may have been
as many as 500,000 but the number is
uncertain and that's part of the problem
it's bad enough that the Russians have
demonstrated interest in tampering with
our voting systems and that we currently
have no way to prevent it but we can't
even agree on what they've done once
they've done it did Russian interference
in the 2016 elections actually affect
the election outcome you can find plenty
of arguments on both sides of the issue
online if you mean directly manipulating
the vote the answer is probably not but
if you mean influencing the vote the
answer is almost certainly yes to some
degree to me however what matters most
at this point is preventing it from
happening again
so what then should be our response to
begin with we need to recognize that our
election system is critical
infrastructure in much the same way that
our electric grid is in fact today's
election system is a lot like the
electric grid was 10 or 15 years ago
back then we didn't think the grid was
gonna be the target of an attack it was
spread out among many states and
municipalities security systems for it
varied widely and we badly needed to
invest time energy and capital to fix it
by and large we've done so it's time to
do the same thing now for the election
grid here are some thoughts on how first
we need to identify best practices for
election security and incentivize states
to adopt them the most obvious is that
every state should use backup paper
records purely electronic voting means
there's no way not to check whether a
vote has been tampered with after the
fact and that should be unacceptable to
everyone second we need resources any
improvement in these systems is going to
cost a lot of money
many states transition ill-advisedly
from paper to electronic ballots after
the 2000 election and it costs billions
of dollars now it's going to cause
billions more to change back or at least
half way back the 380 million in state
block grants that Congress approved in
March 2018 is a start but much more will
be needed third we need to encourage
state election officials to share threat
and vulnerability information as well as
information about attacks as they happen
in real time it's no good if Florida
stops an attack but doesn't share how
they did it with Georgia fourth and most
challenging ly we need to find a way to
counteract the prevalence of bots on the
web and the spread of false information
I'm not advocating kicking real people
off the network or censoring speech but
I think it ought to be common ground
that fake people don't have real rights
and so companies that manage social
networks like Twitter Facebook Yahoo and
Bing and all the different news
aggregation sites they need to be
courage to identify and eliminate fake
accounts that's a good start we can also
learn a bit from our friends the 2017
German elections came under assault in
much the same way as ours in 2016 with
fake Russian botnet attacks fake sites
fake news organizations but they were
much less effective in Germany why first
all the major political parties agreed
that they would not rely on any leaked
information from cyberattacks they
wouldn't republished it and they
wouldn't reuse it so there was in effect
a treaty among the major parties that
said country / party we're not going to
let the Russians do this to us we're
going to be on the lookout for leaked
information and we're going to make sure
that we check before we retweet second
the German government engaged in what
might be called counter speech it was an
education campaign for the German public
about the signs of fake reporting and
BOTS in short the government tried to
teach citizens how to identify a Russian
influence campaign so is not to be
misled by it now perhaps neither of
Germany's approaches is feasible in
America but even if they aren't they may
point us in useful directions finally we
need states and localities to change the
way they think about the security of
their registration voting and recount
systems today in spite of all the news
about Russian election interference many
states and local election officials
still don't see cyber security as an
important part of what they do they see
registering voters verifying their
identities and managing the vote as
their task
full-stop for example if you go to most
states today and ask who's in charge of
the cyber security of your election
system the answer is there's no single
person in charge
everybody's task
maintaining his or her own database with
no one person responsible for the state
as a whole that needs to change
states need to devise an architecture of
management that places responsibility
for cybersecurity on somebody's
shoulders only once authority is
centralized can effective training and
testing be established to prevent the
kind of thing that happened at the DNC
in the Clinton campaign staff at all of
our voting agencies needs to be trained
to recognize bad links phishing and
other common hacker ploys Russia is the
problem at the present moment but it's
not our only adversary and the world is
full of talented hackers capable of
causing trouble if we want to have a
hope of safeguarding our election system
in the Internet age the kinds of basic
measures that I've just outlined are
quite frankly indispensable it hardly
needs to be said that given the size of
our nation the diversity of its election
systems and the urgency of securing
leadership from the White House would
help in the run-up to the 2018 elections
that leadership has unfortunately been
absent and without it the security of
the November 2018 elections currently
appears to be very much in doubt even if
those elections go smoothly and without
outside interference however our
political system cannot long endure
without an election infrastructure that
the voters can trust our system is built
on the idea that it is we the people who
grant our leaders the power to lead us
with our votes we have a right to know
that our votes have meaning and the only
way we will know that is if the election
results can be proven fair and accurate
and if we are confident that the voters
were not mislead on a mass scale by
false news and false social media
campaigns in the name of democracy we
must demand no
less
[Music]
[Music]